que é cansativo cara gravar um filme Tu
é doido todo tempinho que dá eu venho
aqui pra cama dormir aí acordei PR
gravar botei o despertador Acordei com
despertador puto também e despertador é
chato meu amigo espert ador é tão chato
que eu acho que é por isso que a gente
acorda Porque chato não é por causa do
barulho Ah o barulho me acordou é não
porque chato repete ele fica repetindo
tem tem tem tem e tudo que repete é
chato aí a gente acorda puto ninguém
acorda feliz com
despertador Ah que dia mais Wonderful
mamãe acho que vou procurar as mariposas
não meu é doido é chato demais por isso
que a gente acorda concordando com o
despertador já prestou atenção quando a
gente tá a gente acorda concordando
com o despertador acordei Tá bom tá bom
tá bom acordei tá bom acordei tô
satisfeito Acordei já levantei tá bom
pronto tá bom